but what qualities do you look for in a
woman somebody that likes to suck dick
and likes to sell [ __ ] that likes to
make money that you know it's okay she
wanted to get high and all that you know
she don't even got it she don't got to
do [ __ ]
was she with me I'll give her whatever
she wants you read like powder
you're like the Columbian sugar I'll
give you that you want this you want
that you get all that okay so this party
started all right how much teaches look
great
supposed to say amazing amazing I'm
sorry they were they're amazing like
we're making love for the first time
okay okay Hollywood Hollywood where'd
you grow up where're you from
firstly well I grew up in El Salvador I
was born in El Salvador and tell me
about your family he had both your
parents as a kid
well I most of my life I've been with my
mother but I was raised my mother raised
me
with the help of all my uncles I have a
lot of uncles and my grandmother rest in
peace so I had a big love of loving
family and how was your childhood my
childhood with my mom most part you know
the most amazing childhood but you know
there's society that she doesn't know I
was I was a victim of child pornography
so yeah we got you knew that it was um
we used to live in this big building and
um this um these girls I didn't know
what they was doing but there was
recruiting of little girls like me you
know I bet he just came from El Salvador
so once they you know I started playing
when the hallways with them or whatever
they took me to their apartment and you
know they started filming me having sex
and all that stuff I didn't know what I
was doing I was scared but they used to
blackmail me used to say if you don't do
what we say you're gonna tell your mama
and I was very I had a lot of fear until
this day I have fear
how old are you
I'm sorry um think I was about six years
old this was in the u.s. earns yeah us
but I didn't know that was they was
filming me all I remember that lady had
a uh it's like oh you know like though
they had like a intercom type of thing
so when when the mom them I don't love
the mom used to know but that I used to
be the one I'm filming the daughter
saying you know I didn't know but I used
to take a lot of the hit because they
was trying to get you know my little
sister so every time they'll come around
my sister I'll try to protect them like
you know so I used to I I didn't know
what I was doing but I knew that when I
wasn't right what kind of things were
you doing with adults or with the kids
no I was the girls teenage girls what
teenage girls do varies ages young girls
I was six I don't know but I remember
because some of them have pubic hair so
I know there was teenagers so you know
he say have sex and all that I didn't
know you know I didn't know I didn't
like it did anyone get caught never did
you ever say anything well we know we
did you know I it went I don't like to
talk about it because at the end of the
day I wasn't the only one and I just you
know we I went through it for a couple
of years without my mom knowing cuz you
know I was scared that she probably
would have punished me or hit me and you
know my mom was a pretty scary lady you
know we're kind of like the military
type of family you know from my Sabich
door you know so we don't play around
with all that stuff so I should have
told her but I was just more scared like
I did something wrong when I did it you
know but yeah I still remember today we
had the inner cook that I used to hear I
put up there I mean it through my mind
means hurry up your mama's coming
so we'll put our clothes on his stuff
and act like nothing happened play with
our Barbies you know I was sick that guy
was sick yeah yeah how are you as a
teenager while we well I was always been
smart you know straight A's
you know I loved school because again
my mom you know I was raising the girl
home but I've been through a lot of
stuff so you know that side of my life I
keep it away from my mother
out of respect you know I know I never
told it because I didn't want cost her
no pain you know so when you left home
what did you where'd you go man I went
everywhere you know I started hanging
around with the with this you know big
organization you know I was wrecked I
was I knew about this organization when
I was about my new I was into the chat
pornography so every years and then um I
joined you know I don't this
organization and stuff so they were all
older guys but I should see these guys
these guys just took care of my uncle
because my uncle just said so weed so
they used to come and protect my uncle
so after I I started running away from
home I joined that organization and you
know they see some potential cuz I was
you know always been I was I don't I
don't think I'm a you know Jane or Lopez
type of girl I know them you know I'm
very you know I could get the type of
attention of a man so this this
organization started teaching me how to
seduce men and my knee I was underage so
I didn't know what they was trying to do
the whole entire time these guys were
trying to teach me I had to go to the
bars mining base to dress me up as I
older trying to make me older as I look
so they'll show me how to they'll take
me to certain bars it already told me
what I was supposed to do you know what
look you know this guy is there okay but
the whole entire time the whole plan was
to sleep with the guy my older guy I
knew any guy that I thought I would
sleep with they have go changed you know
big cowboy boots thousand dollars Gator
shoes bottles big ol them you know Marco
trucks and stuff I I knew what I was
supposed to do it mind you so I'll go in
there you know we'll go through our
thing or what
and then you know I knew how to take
pictures and all that stuff and you know
what we we knew I didn't know well
that's what the pictures for so my long
story short my job was to go in there
sleep with the guy this guy had
something he was the owner of the club
he had a lot of stuff to lose so by me
coming in in that Club meaning if you
don't do what my homeboys say well
that's organisation of the organization
don't do with what we're asking for
meaning taking more prostitutes in
they're sending more stuff you know
basically free game you can't tell me
nothing because of all we could do is go
to the police and look there she is
isn't that her so it was so easy for me
to do that I got addicted to it so
that's what I'll you know that's what I
was doing so you working as a prostitute
at what age you I don't like you call it
prostitue I'm not a shame but I'm more
like a hustler I'm up you know there's
different layers to it but the question
is I don't consider myself a prostitute
because I just don't sell [ __ ] I do a
lot more then I think I saw that's a
prostitue or a smart prostitute should
be able to sell more than her [ __ ] you
see just like just like any woman you
know what I want to be called a project
even if she is a processor because the
prostitutes that I know they don't call
they're not gonna sit here and pronounce
to the world I'm a prostitute
no they're not one do but that's figure
well because they're not smart you a
little follows they haven't been taught
the game I've been taught the game I'm I
getting so solid my game is worth a lot
of money no when you came to the u.s.
what city did you come to
hey first thing I came to was a
Hollywood I'm Hyland hilar okay Appleton
LA yeah that was the first apartment and
after that apartment we moved down to
Koreatown
and that's where all the you know
starving belly and I started running
away from home and stuff and hustling
you know your story is interesting in
that you've actually you've branched out
into other areas right you have you have
girls that work for you well you see my
case is kind of complicated because I
have over I could say you know not to
you know I don't boast and brag but I've
worked over with 20 girls you know but
these 20 girls is like we have built a
bond you know like we known each other
for over 10 years and these are a real
full grown prostitute like if I could
tell if I tell you a mark right if I say
hey if I bring one of my chicks I'm like
a chick go ahead and suck marks a dick
right now do you think she's not gonna
do it do you think I'm gonna bring
somebody to make me look stupid
No so you know the girls that I do
affiliate myself with this I can't bring
them to my house I can't go down to
Denny's or whatever the [ __ ] we you know
go eat you know by my I separate my mind
my celly [ __ ] day you know my celly
[ __ ] Alice is from 9 to 5 you know 9 to
5 and and it's it's very stressful it's
stressful because you gotta deal with a
lot of personalities you know I usually
how I knock off a chick that's what we
say we knock off or chicken hawking you
know I like a Chicken Hawk you know I'm
a beast not just going to club and
usually when I go to the club I don't
spend my money that's the most funniest
part is I you know I make me that's why
I'm Hollywood I make a scene like a god
I got it you know I got bunch of [ __ ]
bunch a bunch of everything and trust me
when I'm in the club they're gonna be
looking where I'm at and that's where I
get my girls most of the club so I
usually work at this after-hours it's an
underground club I've been working in
there for 10 years that's when I started
my prostitution game started really like
getting hot like hot you know not to
Boston bright but yes so your high-end
clientele huh you have high-end
clientele I'm sorry yeah trust me I have
Heidi Fleiss potential I want to look
out one thing I'm gonna tell you is I'm
not hip-hop retainment portray myself as
a pimp cuz uh mark my words
a woman can sell [ __ ] other girls [ __ ]
you could be Heidi Fleiss but you can
never be a pimp
you can never take that role as a man
that's a man's role what I do have is uh
I do have Heidi Fleiss
potential and that's what I do consider
myself I'm a damn model I don't one I
never want to be considered or try to
play the role of being a pimp
no I want to give my respects to that
and the girls that work for you have
worked with you for a long time yeah
over ten years
yeah so they're happy yeah well you see
there's a different type of a woman that
I've dealt with you know love them you
know white girls also the hardest ones
to you know wheels in because you know
they're not gonna be hanging out with
ghettos [ __ ] you know get a girl
ratchet and all that you have to work
walking with the mink coat with the you
know make sure you know make sure they
see how the guys treat you like who's
that chick you know that's why I am Who
I am I walked in the club I'm like the
godmother and there's also our big shoes
to fill but trust me this is my hood
right here but what qualities do you
look for in a woman somebody that likes
to suck dick and likes to sell [ __ ]
that likes to make money that you know
it's okay if she wanted to get high and
all that you know she don't even got it
she don't gotta do [ __ ] when she with me
I'll give her whatever she wants you
read like powder you know like the
Colombian sugar I'll give you that you
want this you want that you get all that
but you know I want you to make sure
that your whole goal is to come and get
the money that's why we came to get the
braids so what is your glasses
oh nothing you think you answered it
what maybe I did maybe it's interesting
regardless what did you have role models
you have somebody that guided you when
you were my role model listen I have
my first role model is you know where
salt the Blanco is I don't
she's Columba queen of cocaine she's
from Colombia she was a prostitute she
was abused so there's a lot of
similarities that you know she was a
strong woman a lot of men respect her so
that's the reason I have that person and
the second person is you know who Sonia
is something my art is I don't she's a
she's what she's a judge you know I'm
Hispanic when we say I have different
levels but this that's more of a
personal person that I look up to
because she's a first Hispanic for a
person act in the in a high high power
seat in the what you call it I can't we
think about that she besought the soleus
other females that it no she's been part
she's so smart lady she's a judge anyway
but my Thurman my third one is Bishop
Don Juan I can't I can't you know and
everybody can say that bullet you know I
know I know Bishop very well and I
soaked up so much game and I owe him
everything that I have for him I have I
just bought me a nice car I got a
20-inch rims I got my jewelry you know I
got so much stuff that I from from his
game alone from just paying attention
and listening to instructions you see it
Hollywood gets in trouble all the time
you know I I'm not the type of [ __ ]
that sits down and you know then I just
sit down and don't say [ __ ] just I'm
gonna speak my mind you know cuz I got
my own hustle you know but Bishop is
such a beautiful person is that he got
me closer to God and showed me how to
how to move right you know if you do
right right it's gonna come to you you
know mark but but you know prostitution
is is it's not anybody can stay up from
give you an example
when I have to go to work at the
after-hours that's what we call it first
off if it's gonna be if so say I call it
the the Hall of Hell welcome to hell you
know I'm like welcome to hell because
you can become your hallways he'll be
this is the type of club that starts
from 2:00 a.m. - if money's there we'll
keep it open till 12 o'clock or whatever
we used to until you know started
getting too late so the club starts from
2 a.m. to say either ain't a class when
the Sun starts coming up right so mine
is an underground club we don't have you
know it's no flyers and it's worth by
mouth so it's I didn't know when I first
started cuz you know I know about all
the Hispanic gangs but you know there's
a lot of black gangs a lot of stuff
they're the type of pimping and all that
so anyway I first started going to that
club was I started working with this
prostitute I didn't know she was
supposed to it this time I was a square
you know all my fishes tell me Holly
white hand with that whole I'm like
what's wrong with that
you know so she started told me she took
me to that I thought I was matter of
fact so when I got to the after-hours I
started seeing that it was all game fair
it was you know we have three rooms
three rules we have pool table poker
table we got all kinds of stuff there we
have we have prostitutes that come but
these type of prostitutes you see you
have different type of prostitutes you
have the process to the house a parent
applies to that don't have a pimp you
see these girls don't have they have
pimps but they come to make them money
just take the money home - they pin
their pimps don't have to go there cuz -
this place is where everybody everybody
comes to the same spot they could be
whatever gang you are from but everybody
respects everybody because they know who
you are if you know if they don't know
you that's going to be the wrong place
to go cuz you're gonna get you know
you're not gonna come out the same
person you know be traumatized
so I started noticing that
no they were selling [ __ ] so it's
definitely [ __ ] and uh you know my knee
Rd no it's the time when you know I
started having with Bishop and all there
so my game is tight you know I kept
telling my homeboy since I've been there
for over ten years right so the first
three years four or five years whatever
you know my homeboys been testing me
mind because I do other stuff than
selling [ __ ] so you know I've been you
know trying to be part of the goon squad
you know trying to look Hollywood can do
what he can do you know so anyway I
started seeing how how who was in charge
of the of the rules because you have to
pay for the rules but I'm smart what I
did is I went straight for the owner no
I started [ __ ] with the owner so once
I start [ __ ] with the owner
I know that I can do whatever the [ __ ] I
want and nobody can tell me [ __ ] so once
I started messing with the owner you
know a fair game you know I will bring
my bring my little outfits are not even
tell them like can I work here not since
but you know after I getting pushing
like I took my mind off it came in
started dancing you know starting you
know started making people people that I
saw that had money every weekend
spending money there so who that's who I
started catering so mostly I was like a
punk ass here like concierge McCloud
like what's yours yeah yeah I'm like I'm
Hollywood I go to the club do you need
[ __ ] you need a bottle do you need a
room what you're trying to do yeah so
that's what I that's what I I didn't
have a job I made myself my own position
there okay yeah cuz the owner will let
me you know you was in love with me you
know you lose I'm like a little
butterfly yeah you create a position for
yourself yeah yeah so you know once this
the other guy started seeing or I had to
pull they started getting my respects
right so once I started getting to know
the other guys mind you all these guys
are not gonna let just anybody walk in
there cuz mine is about money and you
can't step on people's toes you know so
once I started getting to know the guys
that work there like you know my new
I started hanging out with the club and
I started messing with the owner now I
worked there gave my son my own position
so once I started knowing the guys that
do matter the ones that got the door
then when I got the rooms I started
giving them I started getting into them
too but as far as no [ __ ] but I started
you know telling like look man I'm a
single mom and she you know I need money
you know I'm not trying to give up my
[ __ ] to all these dirty [ __ ]
you know please please please and
they're like all right let's see what
you got and you know we build up a
friendship so we build the friendship
that you know now I have the owner COO
the guys are the security guards the the
ones that that that pimps the pimps are
their mining ok so I can't have control
of the club now
so I come me I wake up at 2 o'clock in
the morning you know get ready you know
you gotta smell like money because you
see one thing about women's life since
the club's opening at 2 o'clock in the
morning you're probably at the club and
you're already you know drunk and I got
me I stay at home I sure I get my beauty
sleep flat iron my hair you know I make
sure everything look right I got all my
party favors my money my stack of money
my champagne bar this is a lot of [ __ ]
to do so you know I wake up at 2:00 in
the morning you know get Hollywood up
getting my car mind you I got a
brand-new car with 20-inch rims I jump
in my whip go pick up about three four
[ __ ] go to the after-hours once I get
in the after-hours you know I already
said oh you know I already spoke to the
girl so look I'm not gonna take all your
money because remember I don't just sell
[ __ ] I have other [ __ ] that I make
money off so I'm like I'm gonna take all
your money but I'm tight you know I'm
the one doing all the talking I'm the
cheerleader I'm the count I'm the
security guard everything because if any
problems I mind you I can't beat up no
guy but what I can do is go up to the
right person say look they're messing
with your girl man
they messing with
so they're gonna come over and handle
that problem for me but I don't I don't
mess with prostitutes like that so you
know I already got I already got squared
off okay
we're gonna hit the club up don't talk
to no no guy you want to get high you
got to sit right there next to me we're
sitting here together don't let nobody
sit there come to try to chop it off and
[ __ ] cuz you got it all you got to do is
tell him who you were who were Hollywood
that's all you gotta say don't say [ __ ]
don't retain them nothing you know just
have fun and just wait for me to come
cuz mind you all they got to do to sit
there and look pretty drink and stuff in
the bottle whatever and I'll go around
the club and and get the tricks you know
I'm walking around doing the hard part
these businesses got to sit down lucky
to escape high and drunk you know I'm
the muffler guys go they're like oh
what's up you know hey how you doing how
many friends do you have okay what are
you guys looking for you know I got for
the you know four ladies here oh you're
gonna come and meet him come over you
want to come and have a drink that's how
I get him you know you know cuz trust me
that the guy so you have to do nothing I
have to do this later because I already
got the room for them I already got the
the champagne bottles for them already
got the Wii for them I then like
Columbus I got everything so they don't
have to do [ __ ] and you know it gets me
stressful sometime it's like this you
can't do and not just anybody can do
this and top I'm tired I'm tired I got
to deal with drunk men all the time but
money I could deal with drunk men any
time cuz they they have money so you
know once once I get the treats for the
girl's mind y'all got about four girls
so I have to you know the whole four
girls can at least take about six guys
put them four girls so I bring the
chicks over you know give them some
drinks oh you want some of this oh how
much do you want for that Oh
everything's free for the time that the
bottles over my [ __ ] already know
that we already got spread you know
they're hot and horny they're ready
so either how do you want to keep most
of them
money pay the house or Holly went to
Hollywood already got the room down the
street ready
you see I got smart it took me a couple
years to get smarter in and make money
without spending my own money okay
so if a guy wants to spend the evening
with one of your ladies huh what is it
end up costing him well you see I'm not
gonna let no meant uh uh have sex with
the woman just have sex and pounce on
her [ __ ]
boom-boom boom-boom boom-boom hell no I
gotta be quick you see guys when they
drunk they don't not it
ha you know might be the first time so
you have to take it easy so mostly like
I said I'm a counselor you know I sit
down with my homeboy or wherever but the
climb blade look do you want me to be in
the room the romani you know what do you
want to make you feel comfortable so you
know it's whatever however he feels you
know but once the the transaction is for
one girl might be worth 500 500 but mind
you I can't tell you how much I give the
[ __ ] because I never would tell you but
that's for one person at least for 30
minutes and after 30 minutes you know
you have to come in and seduce the guy
that's ten minutes you know he's not you
got 20 minutes so you know once the 10
minutes is over as she you probably the
Garrity is already without the clothes
and my girls can make you come in two
minutes you know so it'll be the most
number that's why I don't like to hang
around with girls you gotta give okay
you gotta go there is something no you
know my girls are professional
professional track stars you know they
get any they were they they wanted
through the because of the rabbit hole
do you want this anything goes anything
because it's - some guys they've been
married for so many years that they
don't their woman their wife's don't do
what a prostitute would do you know I
had this one guy I'm a condom I'm a
column Jane Doe I guess he was a white
boy I went to this strip club where one
of my homegirls
they call him naked Barbie I went it to
that club and you know we got him
but my homegirl was such what he wanted
that he didn't know what to do you know
we ended I'm not even doing that but it
was so easy money that just took my
whole girl into the club and it was
about to go down and just you know this
it was easy money but there's other
times that we do have to go in the room
and get naked yeah I've been in a room
with ten eight guys six girls once how
he was in a boxing boxing ring and it
was a week on retired boxer he had his
ring and uh and I guess he was hell with
this older cat that he's like a
Hollywood I need some [ __ ] I got my
homeboy am i all right how many of you
okay booth we go in there it was that
and uh it was clothes and stuff so you
know get all the girls together like
Hollywood you crazy they really do in
the empty boxing ring with like five
older guys you know we took you know
money guys older guys we go we go into
boxing they put the girls in one seconds
I'm trying to avoid the [ __ ] talking
to the guy the one thing I don't do this
was the girls to get the number one
thing you don't do is take the number
from the trig if I bring to a lick you
can't bring no girl and take my take his
number on the DL so you could get money
and cut me out so that's another problem
anyway we go in the we going to uh in
that place separate the [ __ ] have the
guys here
got to keep my homeboys like me stop you
little horny dogs hold on I got money
when guys are drunk they promise you the
world but with Hollywood I don't play so
you know I speak to the one that mean
that we made a deal with and and I'm
like alright then Jane Doe where's the
Beretta you know I got these holes these
hoes don't come out just for nothing you
know my knee these [ __ ] are in my car
they're doing all my [ __ ] I'm there
breathing my [ __ ] the AC I'm [ __ ]
doing everything so blue don't play with
me cuz I gotta come out of my pocket and
paid he's [ __ ] just robbed just for
bringing them [ __ ] over here I gotta
give him some money you know I don't
so you know he breaks out a thousand he
breaks up a thousand a thousand just for
me just for bringing them up for girls
cuz that's my fee that night I just
calculated that what I was worth and on
top of that my knees are retired boxers
or whatever watching guys
they break some more brain that break I
used it for the bitch's mind because I'm
subtracting gas money [ __ ] on top of
these girls you know these girls you
know they cool you know they know that
I'm not gonna take their last dollar cuz
they all single moms and they got it you
know they got bills to pay you know God
knows that I don't I don't I'm not gonna
do that because that's not right so you
know they make they they happy what they
have and I go home and go go go home
take a shower Hollywood also no [ __ ]
did you hear me saying that I'm
certainly [ __ ] I says other [ __ ]
right cuz I know if they're gonna come
for this [ __ ] is gonna be the most
thing gonna be all the [ __ ] put
together for that price you see so and
other time you know I'll pick them up
from my knee these are the girls that I
work over Tony either so I gotta be
selected from the chicks that I pick
because they're different personalities
for different type of environments
because some guys like the girls to be
calm just get high you know suck they
dig you know guys are weird they're like
weird stuff you know that's why I'm
highly when I'm the director the movie
producer what else
executive I don't know but yeah I make I
make sure happy drugs are part of that
picture for you ha are drugs part of the
picture for you oh yeah of course
I can't sit up here and say no but that
don't mean I see no tracks the tracks
are me look I ain't no crackhead or
Nothing I'll make money I'm clean as a
whistle
we Bishop down on it you're a bishop
tattoo yeah half of my know 90% of my
life is Bishop and 10% is Hollywood you
know but that's another thing cuz
he had problems with law hey I'm gonna
be perfectly honest you know as you can
see by looking at me you know I probably
had a couple of run-ins with the live
when I was younger ye all kinds of [ __ ]
but I'm not a crackhead I smoke weed you
know I like champagne I like I have a
lot of drugs around me everywhere I go
you see cuz right it's part of the
lifestyle yes an expensive lifestyle and
you know as you can see I don't spend my
money in all drugs I make money I like
to stash the money I'd like to floss on
the Instagram I like to do not actually
I like to I like for people to think I'm
broke so you see me where you met me met
me you didn't think I was gonna look
like this right that's true yeah
close I can't look like this during that
date I probably will get arrested right
Yeah right
look what personality trait do you have
that because you're pretty unique in
what you do especially for a female what
what personality trait helps you succeed
at this gotta be consistent have
discipline it's like a job you know I
don't I may not punch in but I do have
to look good and my mental gotta be
right because if I'm high cuz most of
these guys is the place where I be at
most of the time these guys can afford
everything everything you know whatever
you want to do you could do you know but
I I have this only nobody but I don't I
don't think that I can concentrate if I
was gonna be high because that's where
we know I've seen [ __ ] lose money at
the strip club dumb [ __ ] just
finished sucking dick and it just come
out mad oh man I lost my money you will
catch Hollywood doing that I'm shot I'm
shot less tonight I'm sharp as a knife I
stand my money cuz you know man you if I
work if I work with it if I have a lot
of people who are in room that's a lot
of problems because it could be just one
girl say one bad thing and the guy is
high and he could go off on you you know
and I'm a woman but I guarantee I have
something with me I guarantee I got
that's all and I have like three four
homeboys already know before I get the
room might look I'm posted up in this
room and moonstone so I'm gonna have
these couple of guys if you hearing me
from this point come and knock on my
door
no that's the craziest thing you've seen
in your years of manis and I've seen you
no parts no saw my you know the chicks
that I've been with running out the room
with the guys while they were all dicks
and stuffing like guys with their balls
I'll just hey hey [ __ ] you better hurry
up
you better hurry up cause you know
that's gonna be a hefty case cuz that
guy's good you know he met we took all
his [ __ ]
they miney if I ever faced a person that
we took that [ __ ] from me that's why you
know I try to do good cuz that's just
[ __ ] up I wouldn't want my dad getting
[ __ ] robbed by a prostitute ways
balls out of shape running for his role
legs that's part of the game right
sometimes the girls are doing those kind
of things
yeah if I if we don't well some other
bodies die you know I get mad when I see
that like damn I hear stuff like man I
could have been me I could have got that
money you know but one day I one day I'm
going I will come across money you know
and I'm not gonna do bad with my money
you know I want to do all right and want
to be a blessing to other people you
know that's why even in this
prostitution game you know I try to be a
blessing to these women you know you
know I carry them in my car if they need
some food for their kids or they need a
ride and then you saw him there from my
[ __ ] you know but I just don't like
to take I don't like to have females
that they feel like they they could do
what I do or try to go around Mike my
back and get my leg cuz I hate I hate
[ __ ] backstabbers I hate them I can't
stand one day I ain't loyal you know
that's why I stay by myself on [ __ ] with
nobody you know I'm not the Kardashian
type of [ __ ] you know one day I'm gonna
get my titties and [ __ ] and all that but
you know I'm not the type y'all cute and
stuff I'm there I want to make money cuz
I you know everybody celebrity around me
but [ __ ] I gotta go home gotta go pay my
bills you know people get pages to you
know appear you know king card as you
get zapped you know parish money [ __ ]
Hollywood okay none of that [ __ ] I gotta
go back home and pay my bills you know
it dislike me for everybody no but I
have never came across no female maybe
we know once my my best friend you know
my shooter my Jamaican homegirl
you know she is just the only type of
honker but she don't do no Constitution
you know that's why I'm Hank I have
different friends you know I thought man
I'm from with honk old friends oh I call
him HP hole partners then you know
that's who I [ __ ] with for that day but
if I want to go to the mall I'm gonna go
to movies or something I'll call on my
little you know but just I work at
Kaiser and [ __ ] you know let's have a
[ __ ] boy
know the business can't do [ __ ] I've
seen [ __ ] try to beat me at the club
walking with them fake me coats and [ __ ]
oh like they fake it to my head of
course like I can't do that
I got $6,500 mink coat I can't do that
yeah but the club I work at it's very
it's very unique
I wish we could take cameras in there
you would have loved it it's the gates
of hell
there's [ __ ] everywhere there's [ __ ]
Colombian sugar everywhere there's
everything everything that you will want
to do there's no wives no cameras
nothing but these highly there's
Hollywood have you been a lot before man
you know why you probably you're in my
head I swear today you could have to be
a psychiatrist I was thinking no but I
hope you know you don't ask me about
that you know what the only love that I
can possibly as a woman you know when I
was younger maybe I you know have a
crush and stuff but my love my only true
love
a man of the opposites will be my son
rest in peace
your son rest in peace Christian
Rodriguez how'd you lose your son um
like I put my glasses on
go ahead okay so you were you were tell
me about your son yeah his name is
Christian Rodriguez he was gonna be 23
this year cuz he's a Dominican he's
Dominican he was in New York and he was
crossing route 4 4440 in New Jersey
he's the seventh person that got killed
in that bridge you know he's a his
anniversary gonna be two year
anniversary actually this November so
you know uh as you can see Hollywood and
whatever but it's a lot to process with
your son's death and huh oh I'm never
gonna see my son grow up you know a
full-grown man with his wife his kids
graduate his car
you know simple cuz he was from what I
heard was he was walking looking at his
phone it was you know route 440 is a
highway I don't know the details but
from what I know is that my son is dead
he was he's never gonna come back
but he's the seventh person that has got
killed in this bridge and I you know I'm
so angry but I'm trying to as you can
feel that I'm focusing I'm trying to
have my energy on something positive
maybe I can help somebody you know
whatever mine do you find focusing on
work kind of helps you
yeah focusing on taking care of church
you know take care of Bishop he helps me
feel that boy you know he helps me feel
you know I have somebody to take care of
you know I don't have my son like it's
it's it's it's hard that I wish I could
know a way that I can hope that the
people that built the bridge the people
that allow for the other six people to
die I wish I can do something about it
but you know I'm just Hollywood and I
can do is keep my mind
this pretty garden but I wish I can do
something for my son you know I haven't
haven't a sec I have another
ten-year-old I got two boys are yet
another self yeah but you know just like
I said my son is it's it's different
it's different
it hurts yeah
and there's the world of that you're
working in as a change over the years it
has for me a for me I'd be up my says my
son's death I'm more colder you know I
don't have feelings like you know like I
say well when I'm out working with these
tricks I used to have feelings like you
know I shouldn't do this but now it's
just I don't know [ __ ] I'm gonna take
everything oh we don't know where she
never met me but that's because I'm
trying I'm focusing my anger out of my
son's death I'm taking their some years
ago was it my son just died a year ago
more yeah it's gonna be two years I wish
I can do something you know look I
wanted to go to New York and just kill
everybody okay I didn't go to my son's
funeral I couldn't I couldn't because at
that time we know son instead we with
somebody dies you don't have money like
me I don't have no money to bury nobody
you know that's why I you know my mom
put that burden on my mom she brought my
son's ashes back but you know one day I
will get money to pay have my son give
my son a proper funeral you know the
king that he was you know and the person
that killed my son
only got five months of probation a five
years I mean five years five years young
- he was young was it I'm Nam Malik I
need Malik Malik not some [ __ ] like that
that's his name I know the guys name but
again you know my heart is nice
can't have hate in my heart I got a but
you know being being into the
prostitution side of you know game it's
hard you know it's it's real hard
especially with my hands all [ __ ] up
you know I got to stay up but drink and
do this and do that while I'm dealing
with my son's death got a deal with
drunk [ __ ] always want to just
want to use me for my body I solved one
day one they want to show I'll show you
off make it make them look good in front
of their homeboys they're willing to
spend all types of money but that's well
I don't care I'll take I'll take all
your money and you're gonna call me back
like a
sucker trying to have me come and get
you more money sometimes I gotta tell
guys I don't want your money
I'm gonna take their last hundred
dollars up their their account but now
I'm days I don't care [ __ ] and you know
what they were when I when I'm around
with Church I don't cuss you know I
don't cuss I doubt but yeah mark what
else you wanna know that's great thank
you so much you shared more than more
than enough already
hey we know you said I made you crazy
right well welcome to the club go to the
club mark I'm Hollywood baby all right
thank you so much for talking to me no
charge
you